how pressing is the climate change issue
well it's somewhat pressing it's one of
the many problems we need to fix in the
21st century But first you need to
recognize it's not the end of the world
you also need to recognize that anything
we do will really only have an impact in
50 to 100 years this is not a question
to be decided over the next four years
this really is something that's decided
over Generations so we can fix climate
change in three different ways we can
mitigate that is cut carbon emissions we
can adapt and we can innovate look we're
always going to adapt we need to have
lot more Innovation because that's
what's really going to fix it but almost
all the focus on on the first namely
mitigation because it makes you feel
like you're doing something right now
but climate change is not about doing
something right now it's about making
sure that everybody does something over
the long run over the century that we
get the Africans and the Indians and the
Chinese to do this and that all comes
down to innovation